Vamos a meternos de lleno en este análisis. Hoy toca abordar un cambio absolutamente monumental
que está a punto de poner patas arriba el ecosistema digital en Chile. Hablamos, por
supuesto, de la inminente entrada en vigor de la Ley 21.719 sobre protección de datos
personales. Apuntad la fecha, 1 de diciembre de 2026. Y ojo, porque esto no es una simple
actualización burocrática de esas que se quedan en un cajón. Es un rediseño completo,
desde los cimientos, de cómo las plataformas interactúan con la información. Así que
vamos a desgranar exactamente qué significa este terremoto legal para el diseño web,
el marketing y el comercio electrónico. Bueno, pues vamos a ello. En el análisis de hoy
repasaremos el fin de este salvaje oeste digital, cómo deben ser los nuevos banners según
el CERNAC, el bloqueo preventivo de scripts, cómo conseguir un consentimiento verdaderamente
granular para marketing, qué pasa con la gestión del e-commerce y, finalmente, cómo
podemos convertir todo esto en una ventaja competitiva.
Punto número 1. El fin del salvaje oeste y el reemplazo
de la antigua ley 19.628. A ver, durante casi 25 años, el entorno digital en Chile ha operado
con una normativa que, seamos sinceros, no asustaba a nadie. Un verdadero salvaje oeste de los datos.
Pero para entender por qué ahora la cosa va en serio, solo hay que fijarse en este número. La
nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos Personales va a poder imponer multas de hasta 20.000 unidades
tributarias mensuales. Es una barbaridad. Estamos hablando de cifras que superan los
mil millones de pesos chilenos. O lo que es lo mismo, te pueden llegar a quitar hasta un
4% de los ingresos anuales si hay reincidencia. Es el tipo de sanción que quita el sueño a
cualquier director financiero. Ignorar esto ya no es una opción. Es un riesgo literalmente
insostenible. Para ponernos en contexto con las fechas, la ley se publicó en diciembre de 2024.
Eso significa que ahora mismo estamos en una fase crucial de preparación, lo que se llama el
periodo de vacancia legal. Las organizaciones tienen de margen hasta el 1 de diciembre de
2026 para darle la vuelta a sus operaciones antes de que empiecen las inspecciones de verdad.
Y cuidado con pensar que esto se arregla un mes antes con un par de parches. Quienes lo dejen
para el último minuto se van a dar de bruces contra un muro técnico ilegal imposible de saltar.
Pasamos al segundo punto. Los banners, según el CERNAC, la puerta de entrada digital.
Esta primera interacción, esa ventanita que salta nada más entrar en una web,
ilustra a la perfección el cambio de paradigma. Hasta ahora lo normal era encontrarse con los
famosos patrones oscuros. Ya sabéis, casillas que ya vienen marcadas, botones gigantes,
de aceptar todo y un laberinto imposible si querías rechazar algo. Pues bien,
el CERNAC exige ahora exactamente lo contrario. Privacidad por defecto. Un diseño verdaderamente
conforme tiene que ser transparente. Las cookies, que no sean estrictamente necesarias,
tienen que estar desactivadas desde el principio, usando un lenguaje clarísimo y,
por supuesto, sin trampas visuales de ningún tipo. Hay una máxima que resume todo este nuevo marco
legal. Para que el consentimiento sea válido, tiene que cumplir cuatro reglas de oro. Tiene
que ser libre de cualquier tipo de presión. Tiene que informar claramente de para qué se van a usar
los datos. Debe ser específico para cada caso y, sobre todo, inequívoco. Es decir, requiere que
la persona haga algo de forma activa y consciente, como hacer clic en un botón desmarcado. Eso de
navegar por una página y que se dé por hecho que aceptas las condiciones, eso ya es historia.
Pero claro, una vez que tenemos un banner precioso y totalmente transparente,
surge la gran pregunta técnica. ¿Qué está pasando realmente en las tripas de la página web antes de
que alguien le dé al botón de aceptar? Porque no sirve de nada tener un diseño muy ético si,
por detrás, los datos ya se están fugando hacia servidores de terceros.
Tercer punto. El bloqueo preventivo de scripts y su desafío técnico.
Aquí es justo donde la ley deja de ser un texto aburrido y se convierte en un reto puro y duro de
arquitectura de software. Hay una coreografía exacta que tiene que cumplirse sí o sí. Paso 1. Alguien
entra en la web. Paso 2. Y ojo que este es vital. Todas las tecnologías de rastreo, cosas como el
Analytics, tienen que estar bloqueadas por defecto. Cero capturas. Paso 3. Se produce la
aceptación activa. Y solo entonces, en el paso 4, se pueden activar esos scripts. Si un píxel recopila
información un solo milisegundo antes de ese opt-in, ya hay una infracción sobre la mesa.
En el fondo, de lo que estamos hablando es de la privacidad desde el diseño. El cumplimiento
normativo ya no es un tocho de texto legal redactado por abogados y escondido en la letra
pequeña del pie de página. Ahora es una cuestión técnica. Tiene que estar integrado en el ADN del
software desde el primer instante. Y, por último, la privacidad desde el primer instante. El
momento en el que el equipo de desarrollo empieza a escribir código. Punto 4. El consentimiento
granular para marketing y cómo navegar la transacción. Cuando entramos en el terreno
de las transacciones y las campañas de marketing, la cosa se pone aún más estricta. Volvemos a los
requisitos que mencionamos antes para el consentimiento, pero hay que sumar una palabra
absolutamente clave. Revocable. Los mecanismos para echarse atrás y retirar el consentimiento
tienen que ser exactamente igual de fáciles de usar que los que había para darlo. Si
bastó con un solo clic para suscribirse a una newsletter, tiene que bastar con un solo clic
para darse de baja. Así de simple. Y mucha atención a esto, que es uno de los errores
más típicos y que más caro se va a pagar. El famoso empaquetamiento. Es completamente
ilegal obligar a alguien a suscribirse a un boletín comercial o ceder sus datos a otras
empresas solo para poder usar un servicio o aceptar unos términos y condiciones. Se acabó
el todo en uno. Cada actividad necesita su propia validación por separado. Condicionar un servicio a
regalen datos para marketing está rotundamente prohibido. Sección 5. La gestión de e-commerce.
Carritos y transacciones. En pleno proceso de compra online, el detalle crucial es entender que no todos
los datos juegan con las mismas reglas legales. Para procesar un pedido, la base legal es lo que
se llama la ejecución de un contrato. Es de cajón. Necesitas la dirección física para poder enviar
el paquete. Pero si lo que quieres es mandar ese típico correo recordando un carrito abandonado,
la película cambia. Ahí vas a necesitar un correo de e-commerce para poder enviar el paquete.
Necesitas un consentimiento explícito previo. O bien poder justificar un interés legítimo muy
bien fundamentado y documentado. Y la cosa no acaba ahí, porque los consumidores ganan
muchísimo poder con esta ley. Dejamos atrás los viejos derechos ARCO y pasamos a los ARSOP
más B. Esto incorpora cosas tan interesantes como la portabilidad, que permite llevarse los
datos a otro proveedor en un formato estructurado. Y una novedad potentísima, el derecho al bloqueo
provisional. Básicamente, se puede exigir que se congele temporalmente el derecho a bloqueo provisional.
En el día a día, esto obliga a darle una vuelta de tuerca tremenda a las bases de datos y a los
CRM. Las empresas tienen que implementar políticas reales y activas para borrar los datos cuando ya
no hagan falta. Eso de guardar información para siempre, por si acaso, se convierte en una
infracción directa. Además, es obligatorio cifrar la información sensible y tener integradas en el
propio sistema las herramientas necesarias para automatizar todas estas peticiones de derechos
de los usuarios. Y llegamos al sexto y último punto.
La confianza como ventaja y la estrategia más allá de la norma.
A ver, es verdad que todos estos requisitos técnicos pueden sonar bastante agobiantes,
pero hay una forma muy inteligente de enfocarlo. La nueva Agencia de Protección de Datos no se
va a conformar con que haya un documento en PDF muy bonito colgado en la web. Va a exigir
evidencias operativas. Es decir, va a pedir registros de auditoría, logs limpios de datos
personales, pruebas digitales sólidas de quién dio su consentimiento y cuándo. La privacidad
tiene que demostrarse todos los días desde el corazón mismo del negocio.
Para cerrar este análisis, hay una reflexión que resulta absolutamente clave. Aquellos que
hagan los cambios arrastrando los pies y solo por miedo a las multas, van a sufrir esta ley
como una losa tremenda. Sin embargo, las plataformas que apuesten por una transparencia
real, que abracen la privacidad por defecto sin patrones oscuros y que den el control de verdad
a los usuarios, esas plataformas van a transformar un simple requisito legal en un argumento de
venta espectacular.
En el fondo, en el futuro digital que nos espera, la confianza va a ser, sin duda, el activo
más valioso. Muchas gracias por acompañarnos en este repaso a la Ley 21.719. Y hasta la próxima.